Friedrich Merz hat das gemacht was
eigentlich immer machen wollte nämlich
sein politischen Zwilling seien
wichtigen vertrauten seinen
westfälischen wirtschaftsfreund wenn man
so will Carsten Linnemann zum
Generalsekretär zu machen er hat damals
nicht gemacht weil der proports ist in
der Partei nicht zugelassen hat braucht
er einen vom sozialiberalen Flügel einen
vom Osten ins kehrt er zurück zu
eigentlich seiner denke und für mich ist
das vor allem ein Signal Friedrich Merz
will die Kanzlerkandidatur jetzt erst
recht die Wahrheit ist ja auch Friedrich
Merz hat nicht viele vertraute in der
Partei er hat nicht viele die für ihn in
die Schlacht gehen man sieht es ja weil
Herrn wüst sowieso aber auch bei den
anderen auch bei Herr Söder ist auch
kein Kandidat der aufs Blut hinter dem
März steht eigentlich sind sehr weniger
und viele haben ihn verlassen warum
verlassen was weiß Friedrich Merz
vielleicht jetzt nicht die ideale
Führungsfigur ist die er von sich selbst
glaubt dass er sie ist es gab einige die
das Chaos im Adenauer sind nicht
ertragen haben einer der wichtigsten
Berater Markus Kerber ist gegangen er
hat seine Büroleiterin verloren den
Bundesgeschäftsführer rausgeschmissen
also ganz so einfach scheint es mit
Friedrich Merz auch nicht zu